squidoo gamer
what the [ __ ]
this is
so popular i have to try it see what
it's all about do i still have my roblox
account oh hell yeah
oh i'm in
anus
nice name
oh i'm number one i'm the old dad i'm
the granddad thing dad
hey girl
check this out
i think it's working
come on
can you push her yeah hi
you think you're gonna beat me you're
gonna die
squid game why is no one talking to how
squid game is like ripping off all these
animes like kaiji and liar game ain't
nothing new right plus what was fun
about those shows was the fact that the
protagonist was actually kind of smart i
don't know how it changes i only watch a
few episodes of squid game you know what
it doesn't matter all right here we go
this is going to be the new fortnight
trust me welcome to squid game people
are already dying what a tragedy
stopping
oh
oh my god
wait she fake died
oh god i gotta keep a chip
[Music]
bro it is not even hard how do you die
in this
ingrid you're not beating me
oh angry died i saw her
oh it goes faster
people are dying
who's dead
ew what is that
he's going backwards what a chad
[Music]
i did it yes
oh they got him
nice
if the cookies breaks it will be
eliminated
is this part of the show because i
haven't watched this
okay people are dying
all right the cookie hasn't broken
cool i am so confused by a child's game
congrats to making it this far it's time
to rest oh wow
oh
wow
it's recommended i gotta forge the lines
all
you could right
come on
vote for me okay
i'll sleep with you
no one tell me okay
all right this is our alliance it's me
yuk dan
oh sorry
i got a baseball bat
does that mean i can kill people why do
i have a baseball bat
what is happening
he also has a baseball bat
[Music]
that classic it was a me oh what a
tragedy
he died this is so sad
i have no idea what the [ __ ] is going on
no no i'm a baseball black guy
[Music]
oh bro i had him all right we're gonna
have to meet up on the other side
[Music]
no how did he survive that that's
ridiculous
oh you're so dead
got him yeah
yeah
yeah baseball black gang you know i'll
keep killing people i don't give a [ __ ]
what are they gonna do
what are they gonna do yeah
all right what is this our next game is
tug of war oh i love tug of war oh you
bet you're sweet ass i got the pewdiepie
key for it i i'm winning this
collectible
guys you're not [ __ ] clicking
guys i'm not dying like this
nice
[Music]
what happened
no
oh
i clicked too fast it broke the game all
right here we go again i guess
that's so unfair i totally won that oh
look there's a friendship happening
right in front of me
come on moon love mills come on say
something
oh she said of course if you want i can
be friends i can be friends
hey
i made a new friend today this is huge
she swore at me yes excuse me i think
pewdiepie is censored in this game
no it isn't
no
[ __ ] you what a piece of [ __ ] i'm
playing with a bunch of infidels do i
have to be in here to start oh
oh
come on guys please i need 111 subs
stop saying no
oh you know him come on we got any
nine-year-olds
what is math related to come on come on
all right i hope you all die i hope you
physics god damn it's so close
you [ __ ] idiot
all right at last three hours later
you're swearing back at me how dare you
child
all right i'm gonna beat this where is
she
there you are i'm gonna sabotage you
push you what's happening
i beat her
no reflexes
[Music]
no
i was just gonna check
oh i'll buy re if i yeah yeah absolutely
oh that's it that seems like a steal who
wouldn't do that okay the victory real
is mine why the [ __ ] is she so tall
that's freakish
let's get in my way rosie oh she's doing
the thing like in the tv show where she
hides behind
a quickie
so fun watching them dying
what is happening there
hey i did it i did it huge
man
dude you're so far behind bro
oh my god can you hurry up or just die
this guy's taking no chances
oh what an idiot
[Music]
all right oh it's the cookie part i
don't understand but hey put the cookie
so literally you just do this i don't
understand what the hell
okay some people died
amazing
bro stop dying
[Music]
draw a circle boom get shot
love it let's go he's so hyped he made
that
all right hopefully i get the baseball
bats i can murder people but if i don't
get the baseball bat i got to make sure
i hind that's the tallest bit
okay i got baseball back nice murder
uh oh no you're gonna die
why why is this woman
you do not hit back you do not hit back
he's behind me
you'll never get me alive
oh where are you running
bro you got no chance
bro i got my eye on you you're so dead
i know the night is over but it's more
fun to kill each other right
all right the stupid tug of war [ __ ]
click guys god damn it super click
no no what is happening
okay we got this we got this we got this
we're i'm clicking for the team oh
they're terrible clickers oh they're
clicking back
click goddammit
who win who won it i can't do another
click i gotta click i'm clicked out
that's huge oh no not a bridge damn it
okay oh it's like fall guys oh this guy
is cheating all right all right
platforming simple platform
simple platforming i got this let's go
there's a way for everyone else to make
them oh that was close that was really
close
uh idiots
get
[Music]
i assume you don't respond i don't want
to mess up this
let's go let's block him
ah
top
six let's go oh yeah all right give me
the baseball bat
i got the baseball bat
i can't swing it
i can't swing my baseball bat there we
go
i think i'm dying and i don't want to
die so
are you kidding me
are you [ __ ] kidding me that's so
stupid it glitched respawn respond i
don't care take all my money
oh god damn it god [ __ ] damn it
that's [ __ ] people use auto clickers
so annoying oh nice didn't even think of
that okay zero milliseconds okay one
millisecond i should click fast as help
right
yo
what is that oh
you can always tell who's the most
sweaty in these games by looking at the
avatars
why is it funny
[Music]
okay i got a different uh flavor
someone died already cool
got a dorito cookie nice
oh i love the sound so much it's so good
someone died at the very last second rip
all right it's baseball time i'm not
messing this up it clearly glitched out
that's garbage all right we'll go with
him
team
he pushed me
you can't run but you can't hide carrot
i got hit this is terrible
you you get him scared
yeah
eliminated the ladders aren't safe like
you think
you're gonna die carrot ah he pushed me
all right the best one
how did girly girly girl 2022 survive
that's dog
all right here we go auto clicker f6
i don't think the auto clicker's working
no we are the auto clicker is absolutely
destroying them
[Music]
i know it's cheating but who cares it's
a kids game
they always think they're so strong
i got zero i guess
yes yes
oh it's looking so hard right now just
like
oh
oh they tried
wow you guys clicked so fast oh dang it
well done guys
thanks
thanks oh damn oh someone died already
what a dummy
all right people keep dying here
oh okay and then there were four
oh it's lagging
oh come on internet
come on internet i was gonna win that
easy
uh all right i'll take that as a win
because the internet
all right that was squid game very fun i
actually enjoyed myself just for the
sake of ruining the fun for children
thanks for watching if you enjoyed smash
like subscribe and let me know if you
want more see you next time
i have new merch represent.com super
happy about this so i think you guys
will like it check it out